professor Eric Betsy congratulations and
welcome to Stockholm well thank you very
much how's life today uh unusual I'd say
not my typical day but very very much
fun how did you prepare for this evening
did you google the Swedish royalties of
course yes you did checked out both
princess madeleine and crown princess
victoria and their wikipedia pages and
so forth oh great so now you know all
about that you got the picture right
okay you say that one should follow once
passion but you wanted to become an
astronaut explain to me what happened
why did you let that space dream though
because because they kind of veered in
the wrong direction so going to the moon
which is what happened when I was a kid
seemed very exciting to me but I felt
like the Space Shuttle was step
backwards to go in circles around Earth
orbit after that so it seemed right from
the start to me sort of a political
venture more than an aspirational
venture okay so instead of the big
distances you choose the extreme Manus
that's right yeah oh so I went to to the
inner space instead of the outer space
and we're grateful for that but I hear
you know a lot about space history right
that's true uh-huh so yup for sort of a
quiz oh okay yeah more thick Apollo 9
yes okay of the hollow nine that's Jack
Schweiker rusty a rusty Schweickart
mcdivitt James McDivitt and I forget the
third guy right and it was that was the
first flight of the lunar module it's
Schweikart and Stafford no Scott all
right maybe you know the names of the
backup crew oh gosh now you're really
but that would be the Apollo 12 crew
right so that would be Alan beam
um Oh God who's who was the other guy
was being right for one of them yeah
okay well I Oh it'll come to me but not
right now Gordon Gordon hundred oh yeah
yeah yes sorry about that yes Pete
Conrad yes if this is a secret hobby of
yours oh well I mean I grew up with it
so when I read books by one of the best
books is by the guy on Apollo 11 Michael
Collins he wrote a book called carrying
the fire really portrays what it's like
to be an astronaut that one probably
hooked me more than any other on on
wanting to be an astronaut yeah but now
you're a Nobel laureate in chemistry is
there anything that could top this
feeling uh well I mean this feeling
isn't top for me I mean you know the
watching my four kids being born is
certainly much greater thrill than being
up on that stage so there's many things
in my life I again to me the award is
nice but but accomplishments are
objective and accolades are subjective
and this is just an accolade in the end
it's a few people's opinion but a lot of
people have different opinions but so
the things that I'll remember when I'm
dying are when the inspiration hits for
the microscope we're working with my
buddy in the living room or seeing in
Jennifer's lab for the first time these
molecules turn on and realizing we got
it and this idea is going to work I mean
those are the real rewards of doing
research not the prize can understand
that thank you very much Betsy and I
wish you a very happy evening thank you
very much thanks
you